we went to go
hide behind my teacher's desk and
behind the backpacks
and
then he shot the little window
and then he went to the other classroom
and then he went
there's a door between our classrooms
and he went to there and
saw my teacher and told my teacher good
night and shot her in the head
and then he shot
some of my classmates
and the whiteboard
when i went to the backs
he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was going to come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
put it all over me
and
what did you do then when you put the
boat on yourself
just stay quiet and then i got my
teacher's phone
and called my away
what are you telling anyone now i told
her that we need help
and chasing the police
in the in our classroom
if there was something that you want
people to know about that
if there was something that you want
people to know about
that day and about you right
or things that you want different what
would it be
to have security
do you feel safe at school
why not
because i don't want it to happen again
you think it's going to happen again